What's up guys? We are back in the lab today and this time with a couple of new toys
These are a couple of real-life pokeballs you may have seen floating around on the internet
I got this one from Dan Markham from the What's Inside channel where they cut open a metal Pokeball
So if you want to see what they look like on the inside go check them out this one's from the devin supertramp
channel where they produced a video on
Pokemon in real life. A couple of good quality videos if you want to see them go check them out the links are in the
Description these things don't actually belong to me. I do have to give them back, but while they're in my possession
I thought it'd be fun to cast them in silicone
So we can make exact replicas and have our own silicone pokeball mold for casting whatever we want
I have explicit instructions to give this pokeball back in the same condition
I received it the funny thing about this is when Devin lent this to me
He asked me not to scratch it up, but to return it in the same condition
I got it
If you set your pokeball down they fall forward so there's definitely some
Electronics or something waited inside that makes them go Facedown
I would rather that these things sit upward-facing at a 45 degree angle or flat, so when we design our molds
We're going to have two designs they come out a little bit better like that. I notice on the bottom half here
[I] can wiggle it. There's a little bit of play
So that makes me believe that there might be a way to separate these two halves. We gently work around the edges
You can actually see that there's a clasp under there
There we go, okay cool so our pokeball does separate into two halves
You can see it's actually got three latches to hold together and this is why it's top-heavy
it's got this really heavy metal button near the front and
Apparently there aren't any batteries in this so that makes a lot of sense as to why it's not working [now] [these] button cell batteries
Are [2016] and they should be?
2032 for this unit but to compensate for that all we need to do really is [just] bend these wires up a little bit
So they make contact
Let's tuck the wires in out of the way and put [the] two halves back together, and it should click back into place
There we go, and now we get a little light-up pokeball you're welcome Devin don't say I didn't do anything for you
Now these balls are mostly filled with error which means if we put them in the container and fill it up with silicone
They're going to float to the top and that's not going to be good for getting a mold we need to weight them down
There we go. I heard a snap
Awesome, just like that our pokeballs gained some weight, so we're back inside
and I packed these things full of as many rocks as I could get into them which has given them a
Significant amount of weight that's gonna be important because we want these things to stay down at the bottom of the silicon so at this
Point let's go ahead and fire up our hot glue gun Gather up some acrylic and start mixing some silicones
So check this out
I've got two black dots on my acrylic and what we're going to do is glue the base of the pokéballs on there
So they angle up at A 45-degree angle [then] we're going to take these five inch acrylic tubes
Place them over top of the pokéballs and use a bead [of] hot glue to secure them in place and make them air tight
The only thing left to do after that is to pour [in] the silicone let them set and see if we got ourselves a polka
Mold now in my last silicone pouring video. I didn't explain how to mix up the silicone, but there are basically two steps
There's the white runny silicone
Which is really icky and Gooey stuff?
And then you have something called a catalyst which can come in different colors in my last video
We used a red catalyst, so in this video
I thought it'd be fun to use purple and we mix this in on a ratio of [1] to [10], and that's by weight
Silicone is really sticky stuff to work with so if you do get any on you
It's a real pain in the butt, so this is why I'm wearing gloves
So let's slap a bowl on our scale measure out some silicone, and then add 10 percent of the catalyst and mix it in thoroughly
5 pounds 4 Ounces 2 Grams
Oh 1 [pounds] equals 2381 point three six grams answers my question, so we want 239 grams of our hardener
At this point you can see the consistency kind of looks like Blueberry yogurt
[actually] looks really good really nice, and I forgot a cloth. So we're just going to set this on my workbench
I'll let that harden up later. All right cool. It's time to pour
You can already see on this one trapped Air bubbles are starting to rise out
I'm just going to help those along by getting a little jiggle
Hopefully those little doodles will help release any trapped Air bubbles
Because if there's anything trapped on the inside that's not going to work out very well for us
Now you can see I made a ridiculous mess pulling this stuff
We've got leaks coming through the sides we've got it spilling over the top
You can see this puddle where the beaters have been leaking silicone, and right now. It's extremely sticky
We come back tomorrow when it's firmed up and rather than having a sticky mess that whole thing will peel [right] off and clean up
Without any trouble at all so our real-life pokeballs are completely encapsulated in silicone right now
We really have no way of knowing whether or not they turned out so did we secure them well enough to the base
Or are they going to float to the top?
you're going to join me in the next video because tomorrow we cut them open rip them apart and take a look at what we've
Got thanks so much for joining me [for] this experiment. I'll be looking for you the next one Doc you then?
you